bis davor konnte ich immer fahren also
ist war überhaupt kein problem ich
konnte ich bin sogar voll häufig
gefahren und es hat überhaupt keine
probleme gemacht wie oder was geht hier
ist euer max und heute gibt es mal eine
kleine story die sich mir gerade bis vor
zehn minuten ereignet hat und ja ich
hole mir aus von anfang an auf jeden
fall was wahrscheinlich wissen meine
eltern sind getrennt
ich bin bei meiner mutter unter der
woche und meine mutter war allerdings
heute unterwegs beruflich und kommt erst
in einer halben stunde wenn ich jetzt
gleich wie aufnehmen wieder zurück um 19
uhr auf jeden fall
hat meine kleine schwester einem
musikkorps unterrichtsstunde oder sowas
gehabt wo sie natürlich hin gebracht
werden musste und ich hab sie
hingefallen
ja das feld getan und dann sind wir
zusammen hingefahren
ich hab dir eingebracht draußen das auto
abgestellt und so weit so gut
dann wollte ich wieder losfahren ins
auto eingestiegen und habe sie gemerkt
kay irgendwie stimmt fast nicht also ist
einschaltautomatik also kupplung bremse
gas die bremse aber irgendwie so leicht
angezogen so was schon mal komisch ist
nämlich zwei dabei gedacht bin auf die
kupplung getreten
heute zünden ist klagt nur das auto geht
nicht an solche dinge so schetter kay
was jetzt los
da habe ich nochmals autor ausgemacht
schlüssel raus getan
die bremsen immer noch so komisch
geklemmt auf jeden fall bis dann
irgendwie kurz weiter probiert und ein
paar versuche später gegen das auto dann
auch wieder an so dann habe ich mich
zurück gemacht auf dem nachhauseweg ich
muss meine schwester schon in der stunde
wieder abholen wollte keine ahnung halt
irgendwie immer noch schnell
zwischendurch nach hause
das allerdings
wurde unterbrochen auf jeden fall ich
erzähle gleich wie bin ich dann von so
einer hauptverkehrsstraße bei uns in der
stadt bin ich ab gefahren und sie muss
sich vorstellen da gab es also eine
abzweigung da bin ich hoch gefahren da
steht halt ist halt eine ampel ganz oben
am angeregt und die ampel war halt rot
und roden und wurden ich wurde einfach
nicht grün
dann hab mir gedacht okay umweltbewusst
dies das mache ich immer das auto aus
falsche entscheidung auf jeden fall
stehe ich dann da die ampel wieder grün
nach einer weiteren ewigkeit und ich
will das auto einschalten und es klingt
wieder nur so ich denke diese scheiße du
stehst hier mitten am hang und hinter
dir erwarten schon 20 autos und so und
dann habe ich also an aus anders so voll
hektisch und die bremse hat auch schon
wieder so weiter geklemmt
also ich erkläre ich noch alles warum
wieso das so kam alles da aber auf jeden
fall die bremsen wieder geklemmt
das auto ging nicht an und ich probiere
das anzuschalten und es geht einfach
nicht ich stehe also zwei komplette grün
und rotphasen und es wird einfach die
schlange intel führt immer länger und
alle fangen an zu hupen
die leute mit so etwas was machst du
also ich hab schon blinker reingemacht
auf jeden fall kam dann jemand aus dem
auto hinter mir und hat gemeint ja ich
schieb dich mal an die seite dabei eine
fußgängerampel hat er mich so ein
stückchen auf dem bordstein geschwungen
dass die leute wieder vorbei konnten ja
okay ich bin schon mal aus dem weg dann
habe ich meinen bruder angerufen der
normalerweise mit dem auto fährt ist
nicht rangegangen dreimal versucht
der liebe sk dann habe ich meinen dad
angerufen und er meinte sogar ganz
komisch so woran kann das liegen kann
mir nicht erklären das mit ok muss jetzt
den sauren apfel beißen und dann habe
ich ja den adac angerufen
ich bin halt noch kein mitglied gewesen
ich habe heute bin ich das weil ich ja
die hilfe gebraucht aber auf jeden fall
war ich kein mitglied ich rufe die an
meinen soja folgende lage ich sitz hier
blockiere halb die ganze kreuzung hier
dass es irgendwie glaube da laufen acht
spuren drauf also auf diese kreuzung und
meine sehr okay ich stehe hier und mein
auto springt nicht an
ist der typ also wirklich ungelogen er
war am ende zehn minuten lang mit mir am
telefon und hat dann so was gesagt so ja
erst mal wo sind sie denn ich höre da
bin ich also also ich war schon leicht
aufgeregt so noever ich habe gedacht oh
shit wie weit stehe ich jetzt auf der
straße können wir im moment eine rein
fand und dann fängt also an nachdem wir
alles aufgenommen hat man also haben wir
euch schon mal darüber nachgedacht
mitglied beim adac zu werden
jetzt hat ja zeit sie können ja ähnlich
wertvolle alben wir habe ich glaube zehn
minuten dann mit ihm telefoniert meine
schwester musste dann allerdings wieder
abgeholt werden
in 20 minuten als ich da stand und er
meinte so am telefon als wäre also dann
fertig geplauscht hatte malta dann
dauert bis zu 60 minuten da ist okay
shit meine schwester ist jetzt dort an
der musikschule ist da gleich fertig und
ich habe kein auto mit dem ich sie
abholen kann und kann nicht vorbeifahren
bei uns jetzt kein handy dabei
das ok die steht ein weil ich da alleine
denkt sich was ist jetzt los mir schon
gedacht dass sie dann irgendwie angst
kriegt oder so habe ich auf jeden fall
raul angerufen guten kumpel von mir mein
bester freund eigentlich mein bester
freund und sie habe ich angerufen hat
gesagt hey wie sieht's aus kann
vorbeischauen
und natürlich raum bester mann hat
gesagt ja macht er dabei irgendwie
gerade bei einem kumpel ist aber direkt
los gefahren hat meine kleine schwester
abgeholt und dann war sie schon mal safe
und dann ist schon mal der größte stein
vom herzen
auf jeden fall kam dann der adac trübt
wir uns angeschaut in ruhe meint soja
batterie ist leer
anleger ist kaputt ok super sonst
irgendwas ganz an gewicht im auto weil
ich wirklich konnte darf bis davor
konnte ich immer fahren also ist war
überhaupt kein problem ich konnte ich
bin versucht voll häufig gefahren und es
hat überhaupt keine probleme gemacht
wird auf jeden fall das sei kaputt und
das und dann hat er gemeint okay ich
zitiere mal in die seitenstraße und dann
können wir das auto anziehen müssen wir
einfach den zweiten gang einlegen und
dann geht er dann springt der wagen so
dann haben wir das gemacht
ich bin in die seitenstraße reingefahren
er hat mich rein gezogen und dann ging
der motor wieder an findet ihr
entstanden wir dort wie gesagt das ist
nicht mein auto das auf meinem vater
zugelassen aber die meiste zeit seinen
kleinen bruder
und er meine soja an oder fahrzeugschein
bitte ok chef hatte ich so ein teil wo
ist das teil
und ich schreibe sebastian wusste fast
erscheint mir dass wir in der ledermappe
im handschuhfach ist eine ledermappe und
greift die alles durch zehn mal nichts
da der firma das thema schon sehr wenn
jetzt die polizei hier wäre was würden
sie dann machen sie müssen den
fahrzeugschein mit für unser chip und
dann hat es wieder ein glück dass er
noch eine kleine ledermappe da beide
fahrzeug scheint in den filmen das
gegeben hat als eingetragen und dann
meinte er sie können übrigens auch
jemanden werden
aber ich mein date angerufen man selbst
mitglied also können sie auch werben
lassen meint du bist du mitglied beim
adac wissen werben
also kann ich machen und hat sich dann
erstmal sehen ruhig im internet den
katalog angeschaut was man sich was man
sich dort wünschen kann wenn man jemand
anderes wird für den adac ja dann stand
ich da und da kam mir vor wie in einem
schlechten film so also ich hatte
wirklich noch nie irgendwie gut ich
feiere auch noch nicht lange ich bin 18
jahre alt und so unglaublich viel an
aber ich hatte noch nie irgendwie so
eine panne
und dann
fried etwas ausgesucht und mein auto
aber währenddessen die ganze zeit laufen
lassen und mich nach hause gefahren und
ich bin ungefähr
immer wenn ich an gefahren bin habe ich
so viel gas gegeben weil ich dachte mir
auch nur du kannst das auto nicht
abwürgen so also was passiert mir quasi
gar nicht mehr so dass ich das auto
abwürgen so in der anfangszeit klar wird
man das auto ab und zu aber eigentlich
gar nicht mehr so der mir so alter wenn
jetzt das auto ab werk schnell
dann ist feierabend den verbindet dann
immer so mit 3000 4000 umdrehungen
angefahren im ersten gang
es ist ein benziner schaltgetriebe und
dann habe ich es tatsächlich nach hause
geschafft und ich bin einfach nur froh
dass ich hier bin auf jeden fall mein
typ anlasser ist kaputt können das auto
nicht mehr so anschalten jetzt steht das
auto vor der haustür ist bis dahin
gefahren habe aber ich krieg das nächste
mal nicht mehr an
ja dann muss ich mir wahrscheinlich ein
paar kumpels herr bestellen und dann
schieben wir das auto an und dann fährt
das wieder auf jeden fall nicht fertig
mit den nerven weil ich stand wirklich
auf dieser kraft befahrenen straße alle
leute rufen mich an und das upload das
lustigste ich darf mir dann irgendwann
so ey ich stehe jetzt hier
wahrscheinlich noch eine halbe stunde
und dann habe ich so werden die mich
alle angucken und jetzt mal das verdeck
aufgemacht was ist cabrio und ja ach so
zu allem überfluss das habe ich gar
nicht erwähnt ich habe jetzt keinen
keinen klaren gemacht wie ich das
erzähle oder so sondern einfach frei
schnauze das krasseste und behinderte
was mich mich voll hilflos fühlen das
einfach dass mein handy leer gegangen
ist
na da hat da dachte ich mir wirklich gut
du bist jetzt am arsch weil mein handy
war komplett leer
da fährt erst die batterie vom auto ist
leer was ihr auch war allerdings weil
sie nicht komplett entladen sondern
hatten nicht mehr genug strom für für
einen start
aber mein handy konnte ich zum glück
noch soweit aufladen dass sie die dna
der cas anrufen konnte
es ist eigentlich keine krasse horror
story oder so aber ich dachte irgendwie
das wäre erzählenswert vor allem konnte
ich mir zeit überhaupt nicht um irgend
video kümmern was ich heute aufnehmen
kann irgendwas cooles das coolste was
sie aufnehmen könnte
deshalb kriegt ihr es diese story ich
bin auf jeden fall froh dass ich zu
hause bin
danke nochmal an raul debatte die auch
sehr hilfsbereit eigentlich sehr
geduldig dass mein tep sich was
ausgesucht hat und ja ich bin froh dass
ich nicht mehr auf dieser kreuzung
stehen und anrufe werde